hi there steve kaufman here and today i
want to talk about
japanese learning japanese how hard is
japanese
remember if you enjoy these videos
please
you know subscribe
you can click on the bell here to get
notifications
so
you may be aware that the american
forest foreign service institute
and i'm going to put a link to it here
in in the description box has put out
their evaluation of how difficult
uh different languages are
based on you know how many hours of
classroom instruction are required to
achieve you know a certain level or
fluency or whatever
i think these
uh these studies these
comparisons are definitely interesting
they have a lot of experience
watching people in the classroom
i always feel that what's more important
than the classroom is the motivation of
the learner
so and very often this means what the
learner does outside the classroom is
more important than what the learner
does in the classroom
so how difficult are these languages
obviously the number one factor is how
motivated you are
also
another objective fact is
the more a language is different from
your own the more difficult it's going
to be you have to get used to new
structures
you have to acquire a lot of new
vocabulary where there is relatively
little connection to vocabulary that you
have for your own from your own language
but
i would say
that so japanese
simply in terms of the vocabulary and
structure being very different from say
english if you're an english speaker is
going to be more difficult
however there are a number of things
that make japanese
easier in my opinion
um and you know when i learn japanese
i i'll tell you i have here i just went
through my japanese collection
and i found i mean i have so many
different dictionaries that i use
because i was looking for dictionaries
that were more convenient that were
maybe based on a romanized uh you know
look up system rather than
basing it on
japanese
alphabet or whatever and
i mean i did a lot of looking stuff up
because i
oh here's another one too
i had to do so much reading and in those
days you know back in the early 70s
there wasn't quite as much listening
material available it was hard work
today
with the internet accessing content on
the internet
uh using link for example
where you can either use our many
stories
where you can immediately look words up
with an online dictionary
it is easier now i will confess that
with asian languages or i shouldn't say
asian languages but specifically with
japanese and chinese we do have an issue
because it's not obvious what
constitutes a word because a number of
symbols come together to form a word so
where do you split where is this with
the boundaries between words so we rely
on different algorithms and they're not
perfect
nevertheless even though not perfect
because as we often say perfection is
the
is the enemy of of the good right the
perfect is the enemy of the good it's
still very effective so it's easier to
do than
when i did it
but
the immediate obstacles with japanese
are number one there are three writing
systems
it's the only language i know of where
there's more than one writing system in
common use
so they have first of all the chinese
characters which was the first writing
system they had
and then they have the hiragana
which is
basically it began as a system of using
chinese characters to represent japanese
sounds
and apparently there were a variety of
versions different characters were used
in different parts of the country to try
to represent these sounds
because of course the chinese character
is a pictogram it represents meaning but
there is also sound attached to that
character so that was initially used and
this evolved into hiragana which is the
most widely used phonetic script
in
japanese so you have the kanji the
chinese characters which are used you
have the hiragana which is the most
commonly used
but then you also have katakana which
parallels the hiragana and it's used for
you know sort of
words that are just sort of
sounds crash bang or for foreign words
and
personally i found the katakana very
hard because you don't see much of it so
remember in learning any
new writing system
it's not whether that writing system is
intrinsically hard or difficult it's how
long is it going to take for your brain
to get used to that writing system so if
you know
in japanese 90 of the words or more are
written in hiragana then you're doing
most of your reading in hiragana and in
kanji in chinese characters and you're
not doing very much reading
in katakana so i always found the
katakana
a bit of a you know an obstacle
but
so so the writing system is a problem
uh problem meaning you have to put the
time in you have to do see everything
boils down to reading and listening the
more you read and listen and
particularly you read the more you read
the more your brain gets used to that
writing system the easier it becomes so
i began by doing a lot of reading in
hiragana because i had kanji from
chinese i needed to get used to the
hiragana so i did a lot of reading in
just hiragana there was a series there
called the naganuma books and i just
read them all the time
stories about you know folktales from
japan or what wasn't very interesting
but just to get my brain used to it all
right
several things make japanese first of
all more difficult it's more difficult
because it's structured differently
but
it is easier in the sense that it's more
forgiving
and what i mean by that is like i have
no idea
or very little idea of the sort of
grammatical explanations of japanese
because it's kind of
japanese to me is like
you know an old suit that you get used
to wearing and after a while you feel
comfortable in the suit because you wear
it all the time it's not it the rules
are not like it's harder it's been like
chinese in that sense it's harder
to really
there are fewer things to trip you up
so when i think of a truly difficult
language or languages i think of
languages where you have
you know declensions and conjugations or
you have gender
so if you use
the wrong gender in french or spanish
it's
kind of a bit of a clanger you hear that
if you use the wrong case endings
i i don't know i'm not a native speaker
but certainly i'm quite sensitive uh in
in french
to hearing someone use the wrong
uh you know gender although i do it
myself it's unavoidable it's just
impossible to go from a language where
you don't have gender and then
you know not make mistakes with nouns in
in languages where they have gender but
in japanese there's no gender for the
nouns there's not even singular and
plural so
you know book is book book on
table
uh
so to my mind that is much more
forgiving
uh
even in terms of their verbs they're
sort of a simple and a more
formal form of every verb so you have
iku
and ikimasu
but you can interchange them so it
doesn't really matter you can sometimes
probably if you're going to interchange
you you err on the side of the slightly
more formal
but you can say
i never worry about it i never spend a
second thinking about whether here iku
or ikimasu is formal you get caught up
in the mood of the discussion the the
the sense of what's appropriate it
starts you start to feel after a while
which word you should be using
you're hearing the people you're talking
to use
certain forms of the word so you're
going to pick up on that
the very formal the very polite is more
difficult
but you're not expected to use that
until you reach a stage where using that
becomes natural that was my experience i
stuck with my hiku ikimasu and at some
point mighty massive shy must whatever
started to creep into my usage these
very formal you know when you're
speaking to someone more senior to you
or
and i wouldn't use the word the forms
for the someone's who is junior to me i
just wouldn't do that as a non-native
speaker
so to my mind those are things that you
evolve into
uh some people
you know find it strange that the verb
comes at the end but
again through enough exposure you get
used to that
uh so there are less obvious to my mind
and i
could be corrected here maybe people
will come back at me but there are a few
obvious grammatical mistakes that you
can make
a lot of the language is
i wouldn't say vague but
you know
for example verb tenses you know
it's it's
you if you say yesterday today or
tomorrow that determines the tense so
uh
[Music]
are you going tomorrow hashtag
tomorrow
the
sort of an interrogative at the end
all of these things are
flexible
and you kind of get used to being around
people who use the language a certain
way and you sort of pick up on it that's
been my experience
some people find the particles difficult
so by particle i mean in japanese you go
watashi or watashi like when i lived in
japan i used to always say watashi now
apparently no one says that they say
watashi i watashi
i have to admit i don't really know the
difference and
you know i presumably in a conversation
i'll tend to use one or the other for
some reason and i don't know what
but it doesn't
you know prevent proper communication in
the language
uh the particles for example that
indicate you know you're going to
you know the direct object so
like this is the direct job anata knee
so the you have these sort of direction
particles that determine the the part of
speech here so
uh
you know the all makes it a direct
object
knee makes it an indirect like to
someone kara is from someone and these
did this show up
after
nouns
uh and it helps to indicate
who is doing what to whom and you can
read an explanation of it but ultimately
you have to get used to doing it it's
not tremendously complicated there
aren't an unlimited number of these
particles
similarly they're
words or at least
portions uh of
verbs that attach to the end of
verbs
which imply meaning or purpose or or or
reason or whatever
uh you know
[Music]
conditional ikunara
and there's often more than one way of
saying things and here again it's
i find it's a very flexible forgiving
language
which like with most languages
it's just a matter of putting in enough
time so
i can well believe that japanese takes
more time to learn
than say spanish because the structure
is very different
vocabulary there's very little common
vocabulary
there are you know loan words from
english sometimes you don't even
recognize them
um
but it's just a matter of putting in the
time
and uh so i do
have
you know i have lots of books that i
bought in japanese including on japanese
sake the insider's guide to sake same
book in japanese
but
i bought us a small japanese grammar
book but i find reading through it i
just get confused
uh i did by just out of curiosity the
living language japanese language course
but here again it's all in in romaji in
in you know the latin alphabet
and
and
lots of exercises so i didn't find that
useful i just think you have to start in
using things like that many stories at
link simple stories so i used to read
naganuma
and listen to it i believe i can't
remember it's almost 50 years ago
and just allow the language to come in
you they come into you and occasionally
you look things up certainly you look
words up
and that's how you uh
you gradually get used to it so it's not
more difficult but it can take
longer so basically that's what i wanted
to say on
japanese
and if you poke around here you can find
a number of videos that i have made
talking about japanese
or
speaking in japanese if that is of
interest to you just go and search here
on my
youtube channel okay that's what i
wanted to say thank you for listening
bye for now